AMERICANS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY ACTUALLY ARE.
SO YOU PROBABLY HEARD THE NAME
JULIAN SANCHEZ AND GATHERED FROM
ALL THE SHOUTING FROM OUR
POLITICAL CLASS SOME SORT OF
INTERNATIONAL SPY WHO HACKED OUR
COMPUTERS AND STOLE OUR SECRETS.
BUT THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT
JULIAN ASSANGE IS OR HAS EVER
BEEN.
HE DIDN'T HACK ANYBODY'S
COMPUTERS.
HE'S A JOURNALIST.
HE REPRINTED FACTS THAT WERE
DEEPLY EMBARRASSING TO OUR
POLITICAL CLASS, THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND ABOVE ALL
TO THE FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT WHICH HAS AN AWFUL
LOT TO BE EMBARRASSED OF AND FOR
DOING THAT, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAS DONE THINGS LIKE THAT FOR
100 YEARS NO PROBLEM, HE'S BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR ALMOST A DECADE
SINCE THE SUMMER OF 2012.
HE IS NOW FOR THE LAST TWO ODD
YEARS BEEN IN MAXIMUM SECURITY
PRISON U.K.
HE COULD BE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT WITH JULIE IN A
SOUND AND NO ONE DEFENDING HIM?
JULIANA SANCHEZ BROTHER JOINS US
TONIGHT.
MANY PEOPLE ARE DEFENDING
JULIAN ASSANGE BUT NO ONE IN THE
HIGHER REACHES OF AMERICAN
JOURNALISM FOR EXAMPLE OF THEY
ARE SILENT ON THIS, WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT IS?
>> I THINK THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IGNORE THIS CASE FOR A WHILE.
JUST LAST FRIDAY, THE U.K. HIGH
COURT RULED THAT JULIAN COULD BE
EXTRADITED, APPROVED EXTRADITION
TO THE USA SO THE CASE IS NOW
COMING HERE.
JULIAN HAS A CHANCE TO APPEAL
BUT IT WAS THE CHIEF JUSTICE,
THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE U.K.
THE HIGHEST JUDGE IN ENGLAND AND
WALES WHO ORDERED THE
EXTRADITION SO IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT AN APPEAL WOULD GO
AHEAD SO I THINK PEOPLE HERE,
THE MEDIA, THE GOVERNMENT CAN NO
LONGER IGNORE THAT THIS CASE IS
COMING.
THIS CRIMINALIZATION OF --
BASICALLY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS CRIMINALIZED
TELLING THE TRUTH WITH THIS
INDICTMENT AND IT'S EVEN WORSE
THAN THAT ACTUALLY.
THEY CRIMINALIZE KNOWING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION SO NOW IT
IS COMING TO THIS COUNTRY, THE
EXTRADITION HAS BEEN ORDERED BY
THE HIGH COURT, I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE HERE CAN ANY LONGER
IGNORE IT.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE GOT TO ASK
YOURSELF AND I DON'T THINK YOU
LIVE IN THE UNITED STATES BUT WE
ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A CRIME
WAVE IN WHICH MANY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED OVER AND
ABOVE LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS AND
MANY MORE DIED OF DRUG OVERDOSES
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF CRIME
PROBLEMS IN THE UNITED STATES
RIGHT NOW BUT THE BITE
ADMINISTRATION IS VERY FOCUSED
ON GETTING HIS HANDS ON YOUR
BROTHER.
WHY IS GETTING YOUR BROTHER MORE
IMPORTANT THAN BRINGING
MURDERERS TO JUSTICE?
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE WHO RUN
OUR DEMOCRACIES NOW WOULD LIKE
TO RULE THEM WITH IMPUNITY.
THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN THEIR NAME,
THEY WANT TO KEEP SECRETS, THEY
WANT TO -- THEY DON'T WANT THE
PUBLIC TO BE INFORMED BASICALLY.
I THINK THAT'S WHY AND THEY ARE
MAKING AN EXAMPLE OUT OF JULIAN
TELLING PEOPLE IF YOU TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT OUR SECRETS, IF YOU
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
SECURITY STATE OR ANYTHING
REALLY, THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO YOU.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE LOCKED IN A
PRISON FOR THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE, YOUR REPUTATION WILL BE
DESTROYED, YOU WILL BE TAKEN
AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY.
>> Tucker: I HAVE TO ASK YOU A
FINAL QUESTION WHICH IS A
DEPRESSING QUESTION BUT I HAVE
TO ASK.
YOU'RE BROTHER IS EXTRADITED TO
THE UNITED STATES, DO YOU THINK
HE WILL SURVIVE?
>> NO, I DON'T.
PRISONERS HERE CAN'T BE KEPT
SAFE.
EVEN THE MOST HIGH-PROFILE
VISITORS LIKE JEFFREY EPSTEIN
COULDN'T BE KEPT SAFE IN PRISON
SO WHAT HOPE WILL JULIAN HAVE
HERE?
I THINK IF HE GETS EXTRADITED,
HE WILL MOST LIKELY DIE.
>> Tucker: YOU MAKE THIS SOUND